die straßen von sankt petersburg knapp
fünf monate nach dem angriff russlands
auf die ukraine alexander woronin und
max der golf sind unterwegs zu einer
aktion für die mehrere jahre gefängnis
drohen in ihren rucksäcken tragen sie
sprühdosen für graffiti gegen die
sogenannte militär operation bei uns
werden menschen festgenommen die einfach
nur mit einem weißen blatt papier auf
der straße stehen angeblich
diskreditieren sie damit die russische
armee
das ziel der behörde ist es absolut alle
proteste abzuführen ob man wegen einer
aktion letztendlich eine geldstrafe oder
was anderes bekommt ist eine andere
frage man will allen menschen angst
einjagen alle sollen denken dass sie
selbst mit einem weißen blatt papier
abgeführt werden
die fünf millionen metropole sankt
petersburg
überwachungskameras und polizei sollen
jede noch so kleine protestaktion
verhindern deshalb suchen die jungs
verlassene höfe für ihre botschaften
unbeobachtet vom langen arm des regimes
sie sprühen schatten auf die wände
schatten zehntausender menschen wie in
diesen tagen russland verlassen wegen
der zunehmenden repressionen und
perspektivlosigkeit
diese symbole stehen nicht nur für
menschen die gegangen sind sondern auch
für menschen die gehen könnten es geht
dabei auch um die angst vor einem
atomkrieg immer öfter ist er inzwischen
im gespräch
alexander woronin ist teil der
künstlergruppe jahr zu deutsch
wirklichkeit aus protest gegen putin
sprüht die gruppe seit jahren kritische
graffiti und dreht videoclips
seine freundin lehrer schminkt heute die
schauspielerinnen die die gemalten
menschen schatten zum leben erwecken
sollen für diesen dreh hat ja sogar eine
professionelle regisseurin engagiert
du gehst bitte in diese richtung am
besten hinter die kamera ok
und los geht's gehen sie aus dem bett
mit dem dreh der videos begeben sie sich
jedes mal in gefahr auch jetzt anti
kriegs parolen und symbole vermeiden sie
die botschaften sind subtil wie hier
eine anspielung auf den von putin
angedrohten atomschlag den auch seine
unterstützer nicht überleben würden
[Musik]
oder hier ein loch wird in den
mutterboden gegraben heimat steht hier
die so die künstler vor dem zerfall
stehe die leiterin der künstlergruppe
anastasia ist mittlerweile im ausland
aus sicherheitsgründen die menschen
bedanken sich jetzt besonders oft bei
uns sie sagen dass wir ihnen hoffnung
geben es gibt noch vernünftige menschen
im land heißt es und schreiben auch
viele leute aus der ukraine die ukraine
ihnen bedanken sich dafür was wir machen
jederzeit könnte die gruppe festgenommen
werden dennoch machen sie weiter aus
überzeugung kämpfen für ein freies
russland
für mich ist meine angst ein aufruf zur
handlung
es ist wichtig für mich etwas zu sagen
schade dass ich nicht mehr machen kann
dabei war ich bei den protestaktionen
[Musik]
nein zum krieg rufen sie auf den demos
in petersburg und anderen städten kurz
nach dem einmarsch in die ukraine
menschen mit plakaten werden abgeführt
wie diese frau mit dem bibelzitat du
sollst nicht drücken ein leeres papier
blatt reicht für eine festnahme aus
hunderte strafverfahren wurden
mittlerweile aufgrund von anti kriegs
protesten eingeleitet
außerhalb von sankt petersburg in dem
5000 seelen dorf rusko wie sonst lebt
ein mann der seinen protest deutlich
sichtbar für alle zeigt auf dem laden
von dimitris curic ihn leuchten
regierungskritische parolen in roter
farbe frieden für die ukraine freiheit
für russland und navalny steht hier seit
februar forderte unternehmer immer
wieder den krieg der in russland nicht
so genannt werden darf zu stoppen auch
mit diesem friedenszeichen auf dem dach
neulich hatte ich sechs große plakate
befestigt auf denen die zerbombte
stadtarchiv zu sehen war so schreckliche
zerstörte hochhäuser mit löchern so groß
wie ein haus unvorstellbar die leute
hier haben dass nirgendwo gesehen im
staatsfernsehen zeigt man solche bilder
nicht
sobald die russische armee die nächste
ukrainische stadt zerbombt oder erobert
notiert dimitris curic ihn diese auf
seinem laden mario pohl
danielsson immer wieder werden die namen
der ausgebluteten ukrainischen städte
von unbekannten übersprüht
aber im großen und ganzen werde ich von
den leuten im dorf unterstützt wie noch
nie am 15 april hat jemand das wort
verräter hier gesprüht die nachbarn kam
zu mir und meinte ich sei kein verräter
und soll unbedingt weitermachen
sogar in anwesenheit der polizei werden
die botschaften übermalt oder
nacht in deren auftrag zerstört
der unternehmer musste bereits über 800
euro geldstrafe zahlen ihm drohen
weitere geldstrafen womöglich gefängnis
sein widerstand bringt ihnen eine
gefährliche lage trotzdem will er nicht
aufgeben
ich habe so eine strikte anti kriegs
einstellung wegen meiner kenne
ich sehe wie die ukrainischen kinder
zerfetzt werden so dass die ärzte danach
nicht mal ihr geschlecht identifizieren
können das macht mich einfach nur wütend
ich drehe durch ich kann es mir nicht
vorstellen dagegen nichts zu unternehmen
nichts zu unternehmen wohl wissend was
gerade passiert
alexander und max wollen uns zeigen wie
schnell der staat ihren protest
unterdrückt wenige tage nachdem sie hier
ihre graffiti gesprüht haben sind sie
verschwunden
die sind nicht mehr da
gegen die penisse gleich nebenan schon
so sieht die zensur in.de ins russland
aus sie finden in der ganzen stadt kaum
eine nische für ihre anti kriegs
aussagen
selbst harmlose slogans wach auf
was ist denn hier los sie machen das
selbst bei schlagworten die menschen zum
nachdenken bringen
wer anti kriegs parolen finden will muss
genau hinsehen oft ist es nur eine frage
der perspektive
putin und seiner propaganda dagegen
gehören die straßen der stadt um den
helden russlands steht hier russische
soldaten verehrung im xxl format überall
in der stadt für die einwohner sichtbar
die symbole der sogenannten
spezialoperation auch in einer der
berühmtesten metrostation propaganda vor
prachtvoller kulisse
max und alexander nehmen uns mit an
einen geheimen ort wir sollen leiser
sein zu groß ist die gefahr entdeckt zu
werden
max ist ein sogenannter ufer er hat die
schlüssel von vielen dach türen in der
stadt illegal angefertigt
unter jugendlichen ist ruh fing eine
breite bewegung in sankt petersburg
tausende junge leute steigen regelmäßig
auf die dächer bitte nicht auf die
kieselsteine treten sondern nur auf die
bretter sonst wird man uns sofort hören
die bewohner könnten jederzeit die
polizei alarmieren und die aktion wäre
zu ändern ich zeige erst mal wie man
läuft
wir müssen geräuschlos und
schnellstmöglich auf die dachspitze
damit uns die leute im hof nicht sehen
können
erst dann können sie unbeobachtet ihre
botschaften auf die dächer der stadt
sprühen botschaften die alle sehen soll
dennoch eine zu direkte kritik an putins
angriff der ukraine kann sie alle ins
gefängnis bringen deshalb sprüht
alexander auch hier verdeckte symbole
sobald das hier trocken ist schreibe ich
wünsche mir ein friedliches brot über
dem kopf ein altes russisches sprichwort
dass frieden herbei sehnt textet er um
jeder versteht die botschaft
er weiß bald werden andere kommen und
ihre aktion tausendfach in den sozialen
netzwerken teilen so funktioniert die
sprache der ufa in sankt petersburg
[Musik]
öffentliche anti kriegs demos auf den
straßen gibt es schon lange nicht mehr
und so viele die protestierende jugend
petersburgs auf dächer und in hinterhöfe
und
hierher eine verlassene industriebrache
in der stadt ein kleines stück freiheit
in der nacht polizisten kommen nicht in
dieser einsturzgefährdeten und
stinkenden gebäude
[Musik]
ein geheimer ort an dem die wenigen
aufmüpfigen jugendlichen ihre meinung
frei äußern können wo sie ihre bilder zu
krieg frieden und freiheit ohne zensur
zeigen können
doch die nischen werden kleiner die
repressionen durch putins staatsapparat
stärker die russische jugend fühlt sich
beraubt um ihre zukunft sieht kaum noch
eine perspektive im land viel mehr
menschen holen sich inzwischen
psychologische hilfe ja die ist
inzwischen sehr gefragt bei jedem
zweiten bekannten von mir wurde eine
depression diagnostiziert
keiner weiß was morgen kommt und wer wir
morgen sein werden das zerrt am
nervensystem
es ist nicht mehr möglich in russland zu
leben und zu arbeiten wie im autopilot
modus leben die leute leben ihr zur
arbeit und nach hause dabei weiß keiner
von ihnen was sie machen sollten niemand
weiß was zu tun ist
zehntausende junge menschen haben
russland bereits verlassen denn sie
fühlen sich hier eingesperrt
alexander max und die anderen aber
wollen bleiben und damit die kritik an
putins regime nicht verstummt